من الفيسبوك من الكوميكس اللي اتعملت على
المسلسل وبتاع امه وبنتها حامل من نفس
الشخص ومش عارف ايه هو يعني ايه يعني
الموضوع مش لطيف الصراحه يعني المسلسل
فكرته غير بتاعتنا ممكن يطبق بره في
امريكا انما عندنا هنا في مصر ده غير
تماما الديانه بتاعتنا وغير ثقافه المجتمع
بتاعنا مسلسل مبني على فكره بناء مهمه جدا
وهي انك لازم تبقى عارف انت بتعمل ايه قبل
ما تعمله
والسبب انك تفهم المفروض تناسب العائلات
والمفروض تفهم العائلات بتتكلم عن ايه
والكلام دوت او يستحق الجدول فني حاجه مش
مش متعرف عليها كلهم استغربها وكله عشان
هي اكيد يعني عك كتير بيحصل في المسلسل ما
كل الجدل عليها اه يعني لازم يحصل اصلا
وانا بالنسبه لي الموضوع مش مؤثر عليا
يعني عشان هو انا مش باخد المسلسلات بسرعه
شخصيه فخلاص يعني لو مش عاجبني ما اتفرجش
مش لازم اعمل حوار يعني زي اي حاجه بتحصل
على فكره في الواقع اللي انت عايش فيه
حاجه بتحصل انيل من كده واصعب من كده
وكمان هو بقى طلع لك في المسلسل ان ده
اصلا ملهوش يعني دي مش امها الحقيقيه فانا
مش شايفه ان في حاجه عشان كل ده يحصل يعني
عادي فكره ان واحد يتجوز بنت وامها وان
الاثنين يحملوا منه فاللي هو العلاقات
الاسريه باظت بس فيعني لا هو يستحقاندا
اللي طلعت عليه بصراحه
[موسيقى]